and this one guy was passed out like
this folded over oh my God and I just
tapped him and I was like hey man are
you okay and he's like he's like yeah
yeah fine and he was like [__] he was
[Music]
Nick you're a big fan of uh Tick Tock
pranks right or like YouTuber pranks
yeah it was my favorite
um I want you guys to imagine
if this prank was happening to you what
you would do this is called the walking
into random people's houses prank oh my
God that's so bad you mean committing
crimes
let's see okay
what the [__]
um
James James
what the [__] what the [__] that's a
nice ass house
oh how rude
damn they're [__] up that is so bad
you know what because they're British
I'm like it's kind of Posh
respectful
is that a crime in uh what is it British
UK
to like uh because I don't know the laws
there you know I mean I would hope so is
there trespassing laws and stuff like
that it's just rude it's just bad matter
it is rude but is it against all like
just the safety issues too yeah yeah
dude you could have been carrying like a
weapon or something I mean why would you
want to like maybe it is just different
out there but like most of the comments
are like due to Magic if that was Cali
or Texas or yeah Florida or something
like that I'll say this oh this guy
looks pretty smooth at being like this
is a study group is this a study group
but then it goes and it sits on their
couch it's a study group yeah because
he's trying to do it for the content too
you know he's trying to make no they're
being they're being messy dude yeah he's
trying to like you like that you get off
on [__] like yeah I love it I'm
commenting and I'm like
I can't believe he did that is that all
your for you page yeah dude that's it's
that
um stuff where like it's like a parent
who pretend like his his wife you're not
a parent bro stop oh I'm not saying I'm
a parent right now oh okay the pranks
where a parent is like he sets up a
camera and he gets a reaction of his
wife coming in and then he pretends he
has like his son but it's really a
stuffed animal the viewers know but his
wife doesn't know and he fought he
throws it over the balcony and he's like
oh my God and then that right oh I love
it yeah people with no with no kids
think that's just funny I get it no I
have kids I understand like what that's
like oh imagine if somebody just walked
into your guy's house and it's like as
part of a Content prank
I'll be pissed I think in the first
you're like you're like it's hard to put
it together so in the beginning you're
like because it happened so quick yeah
because like you don't I don't think
have answers yet you know so it's not
like you have a immediate action of what
you're gonna do but you're it's probably
like very jarring though and you feel
like your privacy is getting invaded
they're lucky they're kids and they're
not in the U.S yeah oh yeah because
we're like gun loving folk uh out there
I'm pretty sure it's not the same yeah
clearly that's nuts too because there's
like multiple kids they're just like in
your [__] yeah what if you knew like as
soon as they walked in with the camera
you knew and you read the room really
quickly and so you played into it and so
you weren't you were pretending like you
weren't and then you close the doorbell
and then you go oh yeah no and then you
go oh yeah what's your app bro let me
add you and then you get the footage and
you go to the police
like look what happened they they barged
into my home blah blah blah in the
footage it looks like you know them yeah
if it's like kids though there's not
really a whole lot that's gonna happen
right like how old do they look I don't
know I don't know how old they are The
Tick Tock age yeah if they're they they
look young enough to be in high school
or something
most of the time if you're just a high
school kid doing pranks like that they
just you know tell yourself like in
Texas it'd be like go ahead and do me a
favor and Close That Dope
let's go to the back part of the house
where it's very quiet
the whole time they're just like oh okay
okay I'm not gonna study I'm not here to
study I'm not here this thing in that
video
the door was wide open yeah right why
why do people just leave their front
some people in the world that don't live
in America are very safe
or something
you know like yeah you just go back and
forth yeah you don't leave it because it
seems like he was trying to get to James
or something right he was talking about
the front door yeah because in Hawaii
they leave the front door open all the
time all of them a lot of them do yeah
yeah because the neighbors watch out for
each other like they're just we leave
our door open a lot of family live
clothes they're just you know they don't
they don't have to like lock it every
single day to me it's like it's scary on
both sides like I would also have to see
I would hate to see like kids do this
and then get [__] up like that's not
cool well you've been hearing about the
stories I don't think we covered it here
but like a month ago there was all these
stories about these random people
knocking on the wrong door
they think it's another address and then
someone shoots them yeah from their
window yeah
it happened like two or three times in
like one week it was like this one black
kid and there's one white girl that got
shot in the head like someone crazy and
also you just don't know what they've
been through yeah exactly so they could
have been like it's just your literally
your worst day but this house got
burglarized three times so that guy is
I'm [__] tired of this [__] next time
I hear some [__] I'm just gonna
shoot and you could be you just don't
know what's happening on the other side
so assuming that everything is gonna be
okay is actually stupid do you imagine
it's like Girl Scout cookies sale like
people and then there's no but they
usually dressed like Girl Scout cookies
or not Girl Scout cookies so they wear a
big hat I have a Samoa
I mean that might help them sell more I
I [__] off
I still got some from last year what
would your reaction be yeah no I don't
let them come out I don't like to expose
them to violence yeah what was your
reaction be for your house like because
you know like you've had homeless people
hanging out on your Port imagine you're
in the bathroom and you come out it's
just you yeah and uh there's like random
kids just like in the kitchen going
through your fridge like three teenagers
I think yeah it might get physical I
think you think so it's a goal yeah I
might like
I'd probably start yelling I might
overreact I think do you think your
actions would happen too fast for you to
even read the ages of the people in your
house yeah I don't think I would care I
thought like I I don't know I think I
with something like that I would
probably snap I'd probably get really
upset do you think we think this
irrationally though
do you think we think this way because
we live in America yeah for sure and
also for the neighborhood that I live in
it's not like necessarily a bad
neighborhood but like
you do see some interesting stuff that
happens on my block like I've seen
different people smoke crack on my front
steps I'm seeing that oh never mind yeah
I'm like what's your address I actually
live but it's in Pasadena though right
okay yeah cool I didn't know you were
gonna show that it's somewhat like a you
know it's like a normal area narrow it
down yeah and it's in between yeah
these are the cross streets but it's but
it's in Pasadena so it's not like yeah
it's a nice area right but they're still
like it is a very nice area yeah but
there's definitely different parts
no there's different parts of Pasadena
that's like not as nice as others okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah which part is that
in between
but like even with people that are doing
something on my steps like that I don't
approach them aggressively sure like
there was one dude he was like
[__] seeing demons when he saw me and
he was like
like that and it's like after he pulled
a hit off his like crack pipe and I was
like oh [__] that's what a crack pipe
looks like in real life and then two I
was like hey man can you just not do
that on my steps please and he's like he
already knew the protocol and he got up
and this one guy was passed out like
this folded over oh my God and I just
tapped him and I was like hey man are
you okay and he's like he's like yeah
yeah but and he was like [__] he was
[__] up and then I went and I was like
if you're not sitting on my front steps
please and he was like yeah yeah okay
okay and I was like you need a second
he's like he's like yeah yeah and I I
went to go back to grab my bottle of
water because I felt bad wow and I was
about to bring a swim and he was gone
and I was like where the [__] did this
guy isn't even real you're saying he's
an angel he's an angel dude but like he
he disappeared so quickly that I was
like tripping out like what the [__]
happened would you say he was pretty
polite yeah he was [__] up though I
think you're gonna go to heaven now I
think that was the test I don't think so
but it was it was a little bit of poison
dude a little fentanyl a bottle of water
there's definitely like a a bigger
danger with any kind of YouTube prank
that happens by surprise I think yeah
because sometimes it's even like uh like
like husbands are like trying to
surprise our their wife right and they
go and then like like Boo and the wife
turned around just socks them yeah cause
when you're surprised you just don't
know and the guy's like oh [__] what the
[__] so like it's it's not even if like
you're in LA or whatever it could be
just people when they're being surprised
across the world you don't know what the
reaction is do you guys like pranking
I can identify with this type of thing
because if I was a kid like a teenager
and social media was around I'd probably
be doing dumb ass [__] too yeah so
you're like you're like a fan I had a
dumbass face but I probably would have
done something that [__] stupid like
walking to people's houses if like at
that teenage year of like I would do
anything like and if there was a way to
show the world like dude that's what
makes it dangerous to me I'm like damn I
get it kind of yeah oh wow but also at
the same time it's like I don't enjoy
that now from either side oh dude I
totally get like making those videos
yeah like if I was that age I would
probably do the same [__] [__] what
is it what do you get out of it because
I don't get it well I think when you're
when you're
yeah and there's just a desperation to
do something that gets attention that no
one else can see anywhere else so like
if they're the first to be doing this
[__] there's like a rush you know it's
like oh damn like we're we're the
craziest dudes kind of and you're boys
too so you're a little destructive
anyway like I remember there was a prank
that people did when they go to Walmart
and they grab a gallon of milk and they
just slamming on the floor and it's like
yeah those kids are [__] idiots
obviously but at the same time it's like
those are just undeveloped brains plus
it's like I can I would never do that
you should lock all boys up yeah I think
so I would never think to do that but
it's a different story when your boys
are like do it do it do it there's like
six of you and like and it's a thing to
do yeah right like we all did all the
trendy stuff or assign every boy with
the dad with a very heavy hand
like if I saw taika [__] throw gallon
of milk in Walmart when he's 15. I'm
whooping his ass at 15. and it's not
gonna happen again I knew if I got
caught doing some [__] like that my mom
or my dad would beat the living [__] out
of him dude you think it's because these
kids aren't getting their asses beat now
because it's it's like child abuse and
everything so gentle parenting well UK
is a little more like lacks about that
right they're not they're very anti hit
your kid yeah so maybe that's what's
causing these kids not to give a [__]
because there's no there's no physical
punishment or anything you know I guess
but it's so it's so hard to like
rationalize because it's still in the
[__] around find out Zone
you get that you know what I mean the
more you [__] around the more
be Asian households that I would know
like uh in the 90s that if he did that
too they'd be like what the hell are you
doing here
like whacking you get your ass out of
here I'm telling your parents yeah yeah
you gotta hit him with the DJ Jazzy Jeff
I wonder if this is
is that what I was wondering if if just
because it's us and where we're from if
that just looks so dangerous to us but
it's really not yeah like are we just
like super sure I'm sure that has
something to do too you can't just walk
into someone's house like that that
looks like guaranteed fatal decision to
me yeah I mean like you're ready to die
and even your vehicle too like imagine
you coming to someone else in your
vehicle oh [__] that I feel like the
first thing you do is pull them out you
didn't even ask questions oh excuse me
what are you doing in here right right I
don't care if you're studying I pull
them out immediately first especially
with kids in the house too like yeah
with that specific a whole family yeah
[__] yeah that house was nice it's super
nice one of my homies his dad is like a
super like scary like cholo dude you
know well and he was like a like OG
gangster gangster for real one time me
and my other buddy were going to his
house and
my buddy just opened the door and walked
in and he was expecting us
and then his dad sat us down and was
like hey don't you ever wow ever walk
and he knew who we were right like we
saw us consistently and he goes don't
you ever walk into another man's house
like that unannounced you better knock
like this is no way to go about it and
he was like given to us we were so great
to hear though yeah but he and but once
you realize that's a sentiment for most
people then you're just like all right
that's just some [__] that you don't
play with because you [__] around and
you're gonna find out right yeah
especially the more you do it I don't
want to do that or even like let's say
there was no one home they could have
had a [__] giant Rottweiler that came
out of nowhere
I just don't even know those are scary
yeah especially two of them two
four-month-old pugs they're gonna rip
you apart dude